UNTIL THEN, TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THINGS ARE MOVING FAST, BUT
THINK BACK, IF YOU STILL CAN, TO
TEN YEARS, TEN YEARS AGO.
WHAT WERE DEMOCRATS SAYING ABOUT
ABORTION AT THAT TIME?
A DECADE AGO?
WELL, THEY SAID THEY BELIEVED IN
ROE V. WADE, THEY SAID ABORTION
IS NEVER PREFERABLE, BUT IT
OUGHT TO BE LEGAL FOR THE FIRST
TRIMESTER OF PREGNANCY.
THEY WERE NOT, THEY OFTEN TOLD
US, PRO-ABORTION, THEY WERE
PRO-CHOICE.
A LOT OF VOTERS, BY THE WAY,
AGREED WITH THEM.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE IT, BUT
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS, THAT WAS
A MAINSTREAM POSITION.
THAT IS NOT WHERE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS ARE TODAY.
THE PARTIES NEW POSITION IS THE
MORE ABORTION, THE BETTER.
ABORTION MUST BE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY REASON AT ALL, UP UNTIL THE
MOMENT OF BIRTH.
AN OP-ED IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
THIS MORNING PUT IT "PREGNANCY
KILLS, ABORTIONS AND SAVE
LIVES."
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S BETTER TO
ABORT A PREGNANCY AND TO BRING
IT TO TERM.
THAT IS THEIR VIEW.
HOW MANY VOTERS AGREE WITH THAT?
ALMOST NONE.
MOST PEOPLE FIND IT DISGUSTING.
JUST AS MOST PEOPLE, ACCORDING
TO POLLS, DON'T THINK TAXPAYERS
OUGHT TO BE FORCED TO PAY FOR
ABORTIONS.
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
DON'T CARE WHAT THE POLLS SAY,
THEREFORE IT.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO ABOLISHING
THE HYDE AMENDMENT, WHICH HURTS
FOR WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR?
>> YES.
AND BY THE WAY, ACLU, I HAVE A
NEAR PERFECT VOTING RECORD MY
ENTIRE CAREER APPEARED TO I'M
GLAD YOU DID, BUT I'M GLAD YOU
SAID YOU WOULD COMMIT TO
ABOLISHING THE HYDE AMENDMENT.
>> IT CAN'T STAY.
>> I WILL WORK TO OVERTURN THE
HYDE AMENDMENT, WHICH MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR LOW INCOME WOMEN
TO GET ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
CARE, INCLUDING ABORTION
SERVICES.
>> UNTIL WE GET RID OF THE HYDE
AMENDMENT ONCE AND FOR ALL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: THE HYDE AMENDMENT.
FOR MORE THAN 40 YEARS, THE HYDE
AMENDMENT HAS PROTECTED PEOPLE
OF FAITH FROM BEING FORCED TO
PAY FOR WHAT THEY THINK IS
KILLING.
CERTAINLY, PETE BUTTIGIEG WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT, AS A MAN OF GO
GOD.
BUTTIGIEG HAS BEEN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS ACCENTUATING HIS PERSONAL
HOLINESS PAIR JUST THE OTHER DAY
HE TOLD US THAT THE LORD
STRONGLY PREFERS HIM TO
MIKE PENCE.
SO WHAT DO ST. PETE OF
SOUTH BEND ON THE QUESTION OF
ABORTION?
HE IS STRONGLY FOR A BEER AT HIS
BASE STATION IS ANY AT ALL FOR
ANY REASON AT ALL IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> MOST AMERICANS BELIEVE IT IF
YOU'D BE UP THE WOMAN TO BE MAKE
THAT CHOICE.
PURSUING A RADICAL AGENDA ON
SOCIAL ISSUES, REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING SAME THING WHEN THEY HAVE
RESISTED A POPULAR AGENDA ON
THINGS LIKE LIVING WAGES AND
HEALTH CARE, JUST ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF EXTREMISM IN THE
MODERN PUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Tucker: SO YOU WANT FEWER
ABORTIONS?
ACCORDING TO HOLY MAN PETE
BUTTIGIEG, THAT MAKES YOU CRAZY,
AND POSSIBLY DANGEROUS,
CERTAINLY AN EXTREMIST.
NOTICE THAT BUTTIGIEG HAS NO
PROBLEM AT ALL WITH
SENATOR MAZIE HIRONO OF HAWAII.
JUST YESTERDAY, SHE BRAGGED
ABOUT BRAINWASHING
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS WHO SUPPORT
ABORTION.
WATCH.
>> PUBLIC SCHOOL IN HAWAII, AND
I TOLD THEM I WAS COMING TO A
RALLY IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT, AND THEY SAID
WHY?
I SAID BECAUSE WE HAVE TO FIGHT
FOR ABORTION RIGHTS, AND THEY
KNEW ALL ABOUT IT.
I ASKED THE GIRLS OF THAT GROUP
OF EIGHTH GRADERS, HOW MANY OF
YOU GIRLS THINK THAT GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE TELLING US WOMEN WHEN
AND IF WE WANT TO HAVE A BABY'S?
NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THEM RAISED
THEIR HANDS.
[APPLAUSE]
AND THE BOYS WHO WERE THERE, I
SAID, YOU KNOW, A GIRL WOULDN'T
BE PREGNANT -- THEY GOT IT.
HOW MANY OF YOU BOYS THINK THAT
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE TELLING
GIRLS AND WOMEN WHEN AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE BABIES?
AND NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THEM
RAISED THEIR HANDS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IMAGINE SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO SOMEONE
ELSE'S KIDS.
SENATOR CORY BOOKER COULD EASILY
IMAGINE IT, LIKE MAZIE HIRONO,
BOOKER HAS NO CHILDREN OF HIS
OWN, BUT HE IS
PERMANENTLY COMMITTED TO
ABORTION BUT STILL COMMITTED TO
IT THAT IF ELECTED, CORY BOOKER
HAS PROMISED TO CREATE SOMETHING
CALLED THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICE OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
THE ONLY POINT OF THE OFFICE
WOULD BE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH ABORTIONS IN THIS COUNTR
COUNTRY.
CORY BOOKER BELIEVES THAT
ABORTIONS ARE A VITAL STRATEGIC
RESOURCE, LIKE OIL OR URANIUM.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
WHY CORY BOOKER BELIEVES THAT.
AND MOST OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES COME HE REFUSES TO
COME ON THE SHOW, SO WE CAN'T
ASK HIM DIRECTLY.
BUT WE WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT
HE MAKES, FOR EXAMPLE, OF THE
ABORTION RATE IN BLACK AMERICA.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMEN ARE FIVE
TIMES AS LIKELY TO GET ABORTIONS
AS WHITE WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT DOES CORY BOOKER THINK OF
THAT?
IS IT SOMETHING TO CELEBRATE?
SHOULD WE BE FIGHTING TO GET THE
ABORTION RATE EVEN HIGHER?
WHAT ABOUT SEX-SELECTIVE
ABORTIONS?
THEY ARE COMMON, ARE THEY
MORALLY?
IS IT RIGHT TO ABORT A BABY IF
YOU KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO BE
GAY, OR SHORT, OR PREMATURELY
BALD?
THANKS TO A GENETIC TESTING, AND
HE ABORTION UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IS EVER BAD
OR EVEN A LITTLE BAD, OR ARE
THEY ALL MORALLY NEUTRAL?
NO MATTER WHAT THE CAUSE OR
STAGE OF PREGNANCY?
THOSE ARE THE MOST BASIC